اكثر تطبيقات الهواتف الذكيه اثاره للجدل
واكثرها استعمالا واستهلاكا للوقت في
العالم
تيك توك المملوك من شركه باي دانس الصينيه
في بؤره نزاع قانوني وسياسي مع الولايات
المتحده ومعها لفيف من دول غربيه اخرى تم
حظره على الهواتف المملوكه للموظفين
الحكوميين في كل من الولايات المتحده
وكندا وبلجيكا واستراليا والمفوضيه
الاوروبيه واخر الملتحقين بالركب بريطانيا
في الولايات المتحده بدات تهديد بالحظر في
عهد ترامب وتزامن مع ازمه عملاق
التكنولوجيا الصيني هواوي والقوائم
السوداء التي دخلت فيها ايضا شركه صناعه
المسيرات دي جي اي التوجس الغربي من تيك
توك دفع الولايات المتحده الى مطالبه ملاك
التطبيق ببيع اسهمهم في الشركه المالكه
للتاكد من عدم ارتباطهم بالحكومه الصينيه
من جهه اخرى تقول بيجين ان واشنطن لم تقدم
اي دليل يثبت تهديد التطبيق للامن القومي
الامريكي مع مطالبه صينيه بالتوقف عن نشر
ما تقول انه مزاعم خاطئه
دواعي الحظر مخاوف من وصول التطبيق الى
المعطيات الشخصيه للموظفين الحكوميين لهذه
الدول وهيئاتها ومنها الى اسرار الدول
والمؤسسات والشركات فاتفاقيه الاستعمال
التي وقع عليها مستعمل التطبيق قبل تفعيله
تتيح للتطبيق الوصول الى طيف واسع من
المعطيات الخاصه منها الموقع الجغرافي
والمعطيات البيومتريه وحركات المستعمله في
التطبيقات الاخرى ولا يختلف تيك توك في
هذا الشان عن تطبيقات اخرى مثل انستجرام
وفيسبوك وتويتر لكن الفرق انه صيني وهنا
مبعثها وجلس الدول الغربيه في ظل تمام
المنافسه بالنظر لما تقول هذه الدول انه
تاريخ طويل للصين في سرقه الملكيه الفكريه
وفي الخلفيه يظهر سبب اخر وهو الفرق بين
التطبيق وشروط استعماله في الصين وباقي
دول العالم
هاجسلامى خصوصا في صفوف المحافظين في تلك
الدول الذين يتهمون التطبيق بتخريب عقول
الصغار فالنسخه الصينيه والتي تدعى دون
تضع حدا زمنيا لصغار السن
[موسيقى]